- Who understands the car accident?
Okay.
Were you just talking to them?
They're telling me.
I go, "You're messing up this reading
"over here trying to do this reading."
- I'm so sorry.
- So what I love about that-
- [Kelly] I'm so sorry, what?
- Validating for you that they heard you,
do you understand that?
- Yes.
- What plans changed that day?
'Cause what happened is
they put me in the car
and they switched my seat.
So that's my symbol for that.
Plans changed that day.
They switched cars or
they switched drivers.
- What?
- Well, we were supposed
to go out together.
I stayed home.
I acted like I was asleep
and she went with my best friend.
It was both of them in the car
and usually when we went out together,
I always took a ride with the best friend,
but since I wasn't there,
my sister did 'cause she
didn't like going in the car
with her and they died,
they both died tragically.
- [Theresa] And you have
been carrying this burden-
- Oh my God.
- For years, for decades.
Validating for you that
they do not want you
to carry this burden of
feeling that if you were there
or somehow you could
have been responsible.
Do you understand that?
Or if you went, this
never would've happened.
- Yes, tell her I miss her
and I love her so much.
- You just did, ma'am.
- Oh!
- She also just told me that you connect
with the song on the radio
that reminds you of her.
It's not a top 40 hit,
right?
- Always.
- Not playing it on purpose.
- No.
- Know that that is her soul,
her energy that is with
you at the exact moment.
So know that she wants
to thank you for that
and know that everything that you see
is truly her and that she hasn't left you.
- Oh, thank you so much.
- Don't thank me, thank her.
- Thank you, Jen.
- She's the one that did it.
- I love my sissy, she's the best.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Do we understand the
hitting of the head?
- That was her, she hit her head.
- Okay, and do you think
that she's suffered?
- I think she did.
It was a tragic car accident.
- 'Cause she hit me in
the back of the head
and then what she did
is she then had this blow to the chest
and she made me feel like
I immediately left the physical body.
- Okay, so I was told that
before, oh my God, yes.
- She says, "I need you to believe that,
"I did not suffer to my death
"or if anyone got to me sooner,
that I would still be here."
- Thank God.
- Know that my soul immediately left.
- Oh, thank you, God.
- I'm very sorry for the loss.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
- I wish you all the best.
- I appreciate you.
- [Kelly] God, you do this all the time.
This is so intense!
- I could keep going.